I want to be the first libertarian on
the Democratic side of the house I think
it's very feasible hi I'm Matt Welch for
recent TV I'm in Las Vegas at Freedom
Fest and I'm joined by a libertarian
Democrat what is a libertarian democrat
dan oconnor he's running for Congress
Brooklyn and Manhattan against a
longtime incumbent Democrat so you're
running a primary election why are you a
Democrat why are you a libertarian what
are you doing Dan O'Connor it's my
strong belief that in in modern day
America there's just as much overlap
between Democratic voters and
libertarian ideas as compared to
Republican voters when you look across
the boards at the issues Democratic
voters are generally against the wars
they're against the Patriot Act they're
against the invasion of privacy they
want the federal government out of the
abortion issue they want the federal
government out of the gay marriage issue
I have no problem with the unions in
this country I'm not going to be trying
to break up unions that's not part of my
agenda they're against the bailouts
there against the large-scale corruption
and the government giving trillions of
dollars to banks and to corporations
there's a lot of room for libertarians
to run with in the Democratic Party
I want to be the first libertarian on
the Democratic side of the house I think
it's very feasible what are you what are
your differentiating yourself ads in
separating myself from the incumbent we
do we are against the wars and we are
against the Patriot Act but I'm against
the bailouts and she did support the
bailouts she also she was against audit
the Fed most of her funding comes from
banks and her biggest donor is in fact
Goldman Sachs which is a big employer in
your district right Tory yeah my
district is Chinatown I lived in China
for six years I worked for a free-market
think-tank and I speak fluent Mandarin
and Cantonese education is a huge issue
for the Chinese people in my district
and the cost of living is also a huge
issue for the Chinese people in my
district they see their cost of living
going up they know that the Federal
Reserve has been printing a lot of money
in the past few years so these are big
issues for them as well as the
unemployment
now you're in New York you're presumably
fundraising when you come up to someone
and say yeah you know I'm a Democrat
who's been working with the von mises
Institute's and I want to audit the Fed
do they look at you like you're a crazy
person or is there a constituency in New
York for this unusual for America basket
of ideas I think the corruption I think
the government bailing out the banks
this is unpopular to everyone both the
Democratic and Republican voters and
when you ask about you know talking to
the people in my district I think that
the debt is a bipartisan issue and
everyone is genuinely concerned about
the debt I think that the the bailouts
according to polls and surveys over 80%
of Americans were not happy with the
bailouts in retrospect I do not think
this is a partisan issue and in fact all
of the Fed was also a bipartisan issue
in Congress last year by the time it
came by the time we came around
Democrats and Republicans were both
supporting it they don't like the
corruption they don't like the crony
capitalism that we see in America well
our viewers what they don't know about
New York State and the libertarian party
and who can run and who can't
there's been no success for libertarian
candidates in New York in recent decades
libertarians cannot run there's no
libertarian ticket and most you
literally can't run if you're gonna run
for city council even there you can't
get the lp on a ballot no nope and
therefore there's a lot of dormant and
unhappy libertarians in New York who
want someone that they can get behind
and there's definitely a lot of
potential within the Democratic Party
especially given that an overwhelming
majority of citizens in New York are
already registered as Democrats when's
your primary primaries is gonna be next
September next September
yeah all right that's great dan oconnor
thank you very much for joining us for
recent TV I'm Matt Welch
you